call a terror group is it possible to
have a Ral I've asked you two questions
should Hass stay in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that on TV on on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
TV yes it is
L tonight on psbg on sensor Prince Harry
prepares to play the victim yet again in
a court battle yet again this time for
his security as the sussexes remain
stonly silent on those baseless racism
claims that they started is it time many
are asking including an MP to strip them
of their Royal titles Israel pound's Gaz
was a 7-Day ceasefire ends with a
Vengeance after telling civilians to
flee to the South why are its ground
troops now moving there Allah last top
advisor Israel government Mark
reg and the shocking new reporting
reveals the depravity of hassing sexual
violence against women why do they take
the un's women's rights body 57 days to
condemn
[Music]
it live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening from London welcome to Pi Morgan
uncensored it's almost four years now
since Harry and Megan made the
groundbreaking announcement they were
quitting the royal family stepping down
as senior Royals moving to the United
States and finding Freedom well since
that moment they've systematically and
relentlessly exploited their existing
Royal status to make as much money as
possible while simultanously trashing
the Royals and the monarchy to preserve
their exposure and relevance I think
it's time we brought the sustic circus
to a formal end conservative MP Bob c is
now introducing a bill in Parliament to
strip them formally of their titles the
Duke and Duchess can be Mr and mes like
the rest of us he said someone doesn't
want to be a royal that's a decision we
respect they shouldn't keep the titles
and privileges if they trash an
institution that plays an important part
in our nation's life I think he's right
and as he also says the baseless racist
and claims that are now embroil the king
and Princess of Wales well they should
be the final straw shouldn't they the
author behind those damning claims who
claims he wasn't the author behind those
damning claims but who else could he
have been the author of those damning
claims given it was in a manuscript of
his own book in which these damning
claims were made Sask lab dog Omid
scobby is still tying himself in the web
of his own lives yeah what a what a
series of events right um and what a
frustrating experience for me for a book
that was so heavily vetted legal eyes
dotted te's crossed and a book that I
was extremely proud of now completely
overshadowed by an event that has caused
me a lot of frustration as well we've
have a full investigation going on into
the series events that
happened yeah I know you're frustrated
buddy but um imagine how frustrated king
charleses or the Princess of Wales that
somehow they got called racists in a
manuscript you claim you didn't actually
draft that way that's frustrating isn't
it when the entire world is encouraged
to think that you were named as racists
little bit more frustrating than you not
being able to work out why a draft of
your own book appeared in the
Netherlands and was translated from a
copy that had the names on it that was
sent to them apparently by your agent
how did your agent get that if you
didn't write it does your agent write
your books
Omid well the times has reported like I
said but earlier version of the book did
contain names and it was sent to the
Dutch publisher Harry and Megan has
stood by in stunning silence so un
likeed them isn't it when private
conversations of the kind that Megan had
with Charles in private letters began to
circulate in this book as well
containing the names of the two people
that she and Harry claim were racially
insensitive about the potential skin
color of their baby now these two can't
normally wait to set the record stray to
sue to go to court to hold people to
proper account for invasion of private
correspondents or
conversations why aren't they doing it
now they claim that they had nothing to
do with omis sco's new book but you
might remember Megan claiming that about
his last book and then a strange thing
happened she was suing the newspaper
ironically for invading her privacy over
private correspondents rather similar to
the situation we find ourselves in here
and when it came to the court case after
the book had been published that she had
nothing to do with she was forced to
apologize because it turned out that not
only had she had something to do with it
she'd given briefing notes to her Aid to
go to a meeting with osobi and brief him
for the book so she was a primary source
for that book so I don't know what you
make of the Silence from the sussexes
we're into nearly week two now of a
deafening damning Silence with weird
right well the question whether they
should keep their titles in my view
comes down to this and it's that if
you're going to spark a race route if
you're going to accuse two senior
members of our royal family of being
racists and if you're going to then
deliberately not say the names for two
years so the whole world speculates over
which member of this white supremacist
family was racist tiring them all with
the brush if you're going to do that and
then calmly as Harry did at the start of
his year suddenly go oh we didn't mean
to say they were racists no no no no
this was unconscious bias that thing
when someone isn't racist but someone
says they were thinking it it was that
but we all know what we heard on
Oprah and in my view they made their
racial charge bed and they now should
lie on it and you can't accuse the king
of this country or the wife of our
future king of this country of being
racists and in my opinion keep the Royal
titles that you've been so cynically
fleecing for the last four years or
maybe you can let's have a debate about
this journalist Rachel Johnson talk to
contributor Paula Ron Adrian associate
editor of the mirror Kevin Maguire and
the author and historian Sir Anthony
Seldon so a fantastically high-powered
panel tonight so Anthony let me start
with you purely kind of constitutionally
historically is it even possible
to wrestle the titles away from
them well I I'm sure it is Piers the
question is is it all worth it and is it
going to be what they want because it
just makes them more out to be victims
of these uh hateful exploitative people
in Buckingham Palace wouldn't it just be
better uh just uh to to let them uh be
forgotten and not to react because by
reacting by doing this the Bob sely idea
uh I think it just makes them into
victims gives them even more publicity
there they are over uh all the world's
headlines again as people there must be
some truth surely in what they're uh
both saying and I I think that that is
not the right way to handle it they're
both clearly two very very damaged
people uh they need help I don't think
they need stripping their role titles
see I would question I would say they're
very damaging people uh I'm not saying
they haven't been through damage that
two but I think they're very I think
they've set out to be deliberately
damaging to the royal family and the
monarchy they've taken hundreds of
millions of dollars to do it it's it is
unprecedented in history for two
Renegade Royals to go off and enrich
themselves making money out of targeting
the royal family isn't it we've never
seen this
before it's not almost unprecedented
Pier it is unprecedented for two members
of the royal family deliberately to set
out hurt harm belal bmch the the the
Monarch uh and the wife of the heir to
the throne that's
unprecedented uh of course it's damaging
but of course the damaging action comes
out of damaged people the question is I
think just what's the best way to do it
and I think uh myself to best way to
deal with it is not to give them the
oxygen of even more entitlement to the
claim of being victims okay Rachel
Johnson your view well Sir Sir Anthony
as ever as an eminent historian has uh
put the argument for killing with
kindness and don't don't give the
grifters any more G to the grifters make
most of their money because they have
Royal titles the American business model
collapses if they're just playing Harry
and Megan not immediately but it would
over time if they can't slap all over
all their correspondents but they the
juk cond dues it
disappears possibly that remains to be
seen we do not know that it could
definitely give them another leg on
their you know grievance tour um I want
to know I mean Bob cely who is the Le
man of life and limb who's you know
withdrawn the Flaming Scabbard to defend
the monarchy and he's he's inserted this
bill this private members bill which is
called something like the disinheritance
of titles Bill 1917 it must be in your
notes yeah so my question is just clear
it's been used before to remove the
titles of his Royal Highness Charles
Edward Duke of Albany Earl of Clarence
Baron Arlo his Royal Highness Ernest
Augustus the Duke of Cumberland and
teviot Dale and ear of armar and so on
this has been used a lot but wasn't it
mainly used to strip Germans of their
titles in 1917 but the Curious irony is
if you took the title Duke of Sussex
away from Prince Harry he'd be Harry
Mount baton which is a German surname
anyway so I'm sure he wouldn't like it I
think okay so the question is who has
the right to strip these Royals of their
titles is it the House of Commons or is
it the queen she took away Princess
Diana's HR which caused Princess Diana
which I can pain for her not to do by
the way huge upset and hurt that was a a
terrible wound for Princess Diana this
this would no doubt be a terrible wound
for Harry and Megan because the Royals
their titles is who they are you know my
the difference about Dina was she never
attacked the monarchy she had her issues
with her ex-husband but I I campaigned
at the mirror to stop her HR being taken
away because I knew how much it hurt
because she told me and because it was
only taken away because she was deemed
to no longer be married to Charles right
but she didn't attack the monarchy Aller
and here's the difference between what
Diana used to do and what these two are
doing it's their deliberate diminishing
and Relentless attacks on the family and
the monarchy that I really really find
offensive now and I don't understand why
if you're going to attack the
institution this much and you hate the
family this much why would you want to a
stay a member of that family or B keep
titles bestowed On You by the monarchy
and the family I I appreciate that you
find it personally offensive peers but
should I tell you what I find concerning
that in this discussion about racism we
know that the institution has issues we
know that in 2020 1 we were supposed to
see the appointment of a diversity Zar
and I'm still waiting for that
appointment what is a diversity Zar well
we can disc we can discuss that another
day ludic title well this is important
this is important the royal family
employed a lot more non-white you don't
want to hear
it it's a fact that they employ a lot
more non-white people than they used to
right it's also a fact they remain
exclusively white other than the mega
marle part of it because they were a
white family is don't shut me down on
this point because this is important for
us you're distracting away from the
alleged racism in this story Trevor
Phillips Trevor Phillips who ran the the
big you see what's happening here no no
I'm asking you a question about this
particular topic I haven't finished
answering your first question talking
about other things I'm not talking about
other things I'm talking about exactly
what you're referencing the allegation
of racism and why it's important for the
for society as a whole for for us to see
that the institution is dealing with
this and I'm saying to you where is the
diversities what racism that we were
what racism where is the diversities art
that we were told was going to be
appointed in we were told that this was
such an important thing and that it was
going to happen the racis because of the
concerns concerns that Megan had that's
what was reported concerns secondly
didn't even also we've also
had and by the way she thought it
happened when she was pregnant Harry
said it happened before they got engaged
shouting me down is not going to change
fact concerned so we also have reports
don't we about issues in relation to how
the institution approaches the concerns
about about
racism we've had unfortunate stories
where I accept there was an apology left
a concern didn't it when for example
princess Michael attended the dinner
weing
herach that honest
believe racist about that baby know
about the issue in relation
to Lady Hy and and how was dealt with
and what I'm saying to you is is that
there are concerns that have been raised
and it we know about the concerns that
were raised what I haven't seen want to
deflect those concerns by pouring hatred
on Haron and Megan that's what this is
about this is about hatred of Harry you
pour more hatred over people than these
two who for four years have poured
hatred on their family and the monarchy
and who did it by sparking a racism r on
Oprah Winfrey in front of 50 million
people where they made allegations of
racism and then tried to pretend they
hadn't they've never produced any
evidence I mean Kevin this is my my
issue with this whole thing and it does
incense me that we are trying to deal
with a story which at the heart of it I
don't think there's even a story I don't
think this ever happened as Trevor
Phillips said at worst what we may be
dealing with is that someone in the
royal family Charles Kate whoever may
have said I wonder what what color the
baby might be that's not racism no you
have a mixed race relationship it's what
every mixed race relationship family
would ask themselves why do we keep
leaving out at the word concerns why do
we keep leaving that word out because
what are the concerns I I read Trevor
Phillips account because he's a black
Britain who's long campaign against
against Against Racism there not
problems with the institution but Megan
markle's evidence wouldn't stand up in
court because it was heay it's something
she said Bas and allegations no no but
it's here say she hasn't heard it
directly but of course they should be
stripped of those titles and I think
Harry's grandmother the queen made a
mistake not taking them away I think his
father Charles now the King has made a
mistake not taking them away they said
they wanted to start a new life but that
new life actually requires them to have
those titles because their meal ticket
is trashing the royal family I'm
intrigued the the failure wasn't in in
about talking wasn't about resolving the
problem you still believe there was
racism even
very careful I have never said that I
could believe it because I don't know so
we need to be care you don't think you
should be incumbent on those who made
the allegations to actually say what
happened um why are they silent in the
last week I I think what's intriguing is
is that you have asked them to be silent
for so long and now you are demanding
that they speak if they do speak
demanding they
clarify
you the boy they cooperated with on the
last why he's able to
Harry's father right and his
sister-in-law as too racists and they
say nothing they say nothing do you
think that if you continue to shout me
down I think you got to answer some
question at some stage allow literally
are behav like a politician if you
allowed me to if you can if you allowed
me to the fact is should they respond to
this absolutely they should respond to
this should King Charles and and Kate
have an opportunity to respond to it
absolutely do you know what I would like
to see in terms of a response I'd like
to be see a joint response I would like
them to come together and send out joint
response don't talk to each other well
then they need to
find they need to find somebody who does
because this isn't unusual peers the
fact that this is a for out in a family
is
unusual one Kevin wants them to be
stripped of their titles uh Bob cely
wants them to be stripped of their tit I
want them to be stripped the fact
remains that you could strip them of the
titled Duke and Duchess of Sussex but
you cannot remove the fact that he is a
of the blood you stop calling stop
calling I don't think you can I think I
think it's literally like all right
let's turn to let's turn quickly to
something else which is while we've got
santony I want to ask you about um this
whole fiori over Kama appearing to
praise uh Margaret Thatcher as one of
the great uh biographers of our Prime
Ministers over the years what do you
make of this is it is it political
expediency a smart move or is it
potential political suicide
side it's a smart move it's a smart move
and uh Tony Blair lent out towards
Margaret satcher Gordon Brown had her
into tea in Downing Street Gordon Brown
to the left of Tony Blair had The Iron
Lady into Downing Street for two hours
and uh the press release afterwards said
there was a a meeting of Mines I mean
look Piers we are a conservative Nation
labor is only going to win if it
attracts significant Middle Ground Tory
voters and what better thing to do than
attract the one truly successful
conservative leader of the last 50 years
and that is Margaret satcher and to to
praise her is simply smart politics but
also it's showing that uh he wants to be
like her he wants to be that leader
coming in at the beginning of a single
party period of long domination labor
could be in power for 10 15 years he
wants to be a figure like thater who
started that period off or like Clement
Atley one of his Heroes maybe even like
Blair himself although he's a bit more
muted about that so smart smart move
smart electorally smart politically
Smart in terms of his own Mark as a
leader okay guess three smarts from the
great historian Kevin you were smarting
as you heard that I was actually yeah I
think look Britain's a Social Democratic
Nation not a conservative Nation all all
our values are social Dem Democratic I
think um why have we voted conservative
the last 15 years that's because the
opposition is split between labor
liberal Democrats and Nats who are all
in a similar similar pool but the
concert are very good as a ruling party
of coalescing but is he not quite no
it's not I'll tell you why it's
not because wounds are still so deep
from her reign in the 80s when so many
people suffered from greed is good fat
cats roaring ahead flogging off National
Assets on the chip to our mates trying
to trade unions turbocharging
inequality he didn't have to do this and
you can tell and I follow I followed him
through this you can tell he's now tired
of it and he'll wish he hadn't done it
because he's getting so much criticism
amazing because I was beginning to
wonder when Kama would give the the
Lefty commentariat something you know to
be angry about and finally hang on we no
we years actually ditched
his sto being a looney Lefty they've all
gone bunkers yeah ever since he saw the
light it became relatively normal no but
now they've got something to give him a
pop hat for and um what you think I
thought it was a calculated risk I think
it's going to pay off because people
think margarth Atcher was one of the
great Prime Ministers and of course she
came to power on the back of Labor votes
he's going to come to power on the back
of Labor votes as well and we have we
have votes even J during her Reign the
majority of people were against her
because she could win on the elector
system we have with a minority of the
votes you know what she kept winning
elections because the opposition was
split but this idea Ed now Paul if you
don't win elections you don't you don't
have power the opposition well you need
an electoral you need you need look at
me I know you don't want to or answer my
questions but quick verdict smart move
or not smart move yeah smart move had to
be done all right interesting mostly
most people think it's a smart move I
think it's a smart move I think he's a
smart guy and if things stay as are he's
heading into Power he yeah but the
conservatives are making uh a very good
job of ensuring someone here's brother
could tell you a year a long time in
politic as he found
out are you looking forward to seeing
your brother in the co inquiry this week
I think it's tomorrow isn't it tomorrow
is it yeah yeah well I I'm not gonna I'm
gon to recuse myself on that subject
just get into trouble yeah because you
don't agree with him good to see you all
of you thank you very much and Sir
Anthony thank you very much un of next
millions of gardens are Sheltering in
the south of the Gaza Strip after being
ordered to lead the north now Israel
stepping up its attacks there too so
where civilians supposed to go what are
they going to go back to Israel
government spokesman Mark Reger joins me
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online onun your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's is
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swearing off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £1
140 million so far so million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking Li if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan should have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegan's about
the weirdest plank that we've had in
three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man M he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
political broadcast on beh of the reform
UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question
are you prepared to call a terror group
is it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
welcome back well days after a truce
with Hamas collapse Israeli forces have
turned their focus to Southern Gaza
hitting areas where hundreds of
thousands of Palestinians have sought
shelter since the start of the war
turkey's president erdogan today
denounced Benjamin Netanyahu as a
butcher and said he would eventually be
tried as a war criminal well joining me
now from Tel Aviv as a prime minister
senior adviser Mark regf Mr Reg thank
you very much indeed for joining me
again your reaction first of all my
pleasure your reaction first of all to
president erdogan he said that of the
Prime Minister Beyond being a war
criminal Netanyahu is the Butcher of
Gaza right now will be tried as the
Butcher of Gaza just as mosovich was
tried what is your reaction to
that I of course don't accept the
criticism and unfortunately this is not
out of uh out of U character for for the
Turkish leadership which has of course
been very critical over the years of of
Israel and very supportive I should say
of
Hamas the big question now is exactly
what is the game plan for Israel you're
moving into the South there are as we
know 2 million Palestinians now crowded
into a 90 square mile area um this is
already clearly I would say indisputably
a humanitarian crisis there but also
they were told to go south to be safe
now they're being attacked in the south
nowhere is safe now in Gaza would you
accept
that no when we when we told people to
relocate to the South it was true the
the fighting was concentrating in the
north and we asked people to move to the
South because they'd be safer and that
was true then now the operation is
continuing into areas of the South and
we've specified as has been widely
reported specific areas in the South
which remain safer zones and we've urged
people to Rel locate there now we know
it's difficult to move uh my father was
a refugee he had to move from place to
place in the second world war to to save
his life I know it's difficult to move
but surely it's better to move than it
is to stay in a combat zone and get
caught up in crossfire it's all a matter
of managing risk we want to see
civilians outside combat zones we don't
want to see them accidentally hurt it's
best for them to move and the truth is
we're seeing now gazin are voting with
their feet and are moving to the areas
which we've specified as safer areas but
eventually this operation is going to
clearly lead to you attacking all over
Gaza where do they eventually move all
these people is the operation actually
designed to permanently displace the
Palestinian people as some
fear no not at all and we hope that
people can when the fighting is over
that people can go back to their homes
and where homes have been destroyed
because of the fighting there'll be
temporary shelters for them I hope but
but it is common sense our enemy is
Hamas and as you know Hamas has embedded
itself in civilian neighborhoods in
mosques in schools uh in hospitals
unfortunately and and we've had to fight
Kamas and we will defeat Kamas but once
Kamas is defeated of course we'll be
allowing people to return to their homes
and of course there'll be a massive
rebuilding reconstruction campaign of
Gaza that's going to be needed how many
terrorists have you
killed so I can't give you an exact
amount because the war is still going on
but we we see the the death hole in in
in fatalities on the terrorist side in
the thousands but if you don't know how
do you know if you know what I mean well
we've got we've got estimates but
because we're not sure and I'll explain
to you why we're not sure you you blow
up an underground bunker yes which Kamas
has got these Underground fortifications
Across the gas strip you destroy it you
don't necessarily know if there were 10
terorists inside or 20 or 50 yes because
you've destroyed an un
underground fortification so it's all
based on approximations when this is
over I think we'll have a more precise
understanding of the numbers but I've
been in briefings and I I've heard the
numbers it's in the thousands right I
mean I hear this from the Israeli side
but nobody seems to be able to produce
any concrete evidence and I understand
slightly the fog of War but the
significance of this is that if you
can't actually produce hard evidence of
how many Hamas terrorists you're you're
killing and the death toll of innocent
civilians keeps rising and rising and
Rising as it has done now over 15 ,000
by the Hamas run Health authorities
estimation you know you know the public
appr probium that's coming Israel's way
the longer this goes on isn't it
incumbent on Israel to actually be able
to produce clear evidence of the volume
of Hamas terrorists you're killing
because if there are 35,000 of them and
you've only killed a thousand or 2,000
so far then the fear is that the
civilian death toll is going to be a
100,000 200,000 before you can even
think about eradicating Hamas what is
the the line for Israel is there one or
is there no limit on civilian casualties
so long as you still got Hamas terrorist
to
kill so first of all we don't want to
see a single civilian casualty you've
heard me say that before and we mean it
we don't want to see civilians caught up
in the cross FR that's why we're urging
people to leave combat zones it's common
sense if we don't want to see them get
caught up in the fighting between the
Israeli Defense Forces and Kamas please
we urge people to leave combat zones and
most of the the the civilians do so
Hamas as you know and has been reported
they've urged people to stay ordered
people to stay even at gunpoint because
they want those G and civilians as a
human shield but white right-minded
person agrees to be a human shield foras
of course they want to leave and we have
to facilitate their leave and even now
as as we move towards our ground
incursion in the South I can assure you
that Escape routs will be there for the
civilians to still reach the safe areas
because we don't want to see them come
into Harm's Way and we'll make every
effort possible about the numbers and
you ask a good question uh look we could
just articulate numbers the way Kamas
does and just make them up and and throw
them out there no we're very precise and
if we don't have a precise number we're
not going to make one up when you say
when I say in the thousands I know what
I'm talking about it's more than 2,000
it's in the thousands uh but we don't
want to say numbers that we're not 100%
sure but I can say something that we are
sure of uh look we're fighting a
difficult war against a brutal terrorist
organization in in an urban area and we
if we compare ourselves to let's say
what what the West did against Isis in
places like mosul and and and fua I am
sure when this is over and you can have
me back if this is not true but I am
sure because I know this to be the the
case when one looks at the the what what
they the experts call the the combat to
civilian death ratio yes and you will
compare the idf's behavior in Gaza
together with against what the West did
in let's say places like MOS I think the
IDF is going to come out very favorably
how favorably will Israel come out with
what's going on with the settlers on the
West Bank I watched a very disturbing
report on the BBC from Jeremy Bowen
tonight where there is clear huge
aggression from Israeli settlers against
Palestinians a lot of deaths and Hamas
are not involved there they're not the
controlling body how do you feel about
that so first of all we did have a
terrible terrorist attack in Jerusalem
just a few days ago where Kamas shot at
people
waiting at a bus stop on their way to
work I think that was was that Friday
morning or Thursday morning last week
that was widely reported Kamas doesn't
control the West Bank but Kamas has
violent cells across the West Bank that
are there and they've wanted to activate
those cells and that's why we we had
those murderous attacks in Jerusalem
just a few days ago Kamas is there
they're more Underground on the West
Bank but they're still a threat and
we've tried to be as proactive as we can
be in trying to go out there and arrest
Kamas activists look Kamas in gazra is
under a lot of pressure so they've sent
messages to all their cells in the West
Bank this is a time for you guys to kill
Jews yes and and they succeeded
unfortunately last week but we have
limited their ability to to kill people
by being proactive arresting people in
the middle of the
night does wiping out
Villages um and looking like you are
encroaching more and more with the
settlements throughout this conflict is
that not just incredibly inflammatory uh
to the Palestinian people living in the
West Bank
appears there's been no Villages that
have been wiped out I literally saw one
on thec where where it's been almost
demolished and the people have been
displaced 200 or so had been displaced
permanently so so once again I'm not
sure what you're talking about and I
apologize for not having that
information but the Israeli policy on
the West Bank is to Live and Let Live
yes and are not involved in vience with
respect that's not that's not what's
beenen I disagree I mean it's obviously
been a difficult period but we have so
far man manag to keep and despite the
fatalities we had last week yes it could
be a lot worse but through our actions
we've managed to keep the level of
violence on the West Bank relatively low
I mean the Hamas people want to see an
explosion on the West Bank that's what
they want they want to see Hamas
activists get on the on on on Jeeps like
they did in Gaza and come into Jewish
communities and butcher people that's
what they want to see and so far once
again we had fatalities last week but I
think overall we've managed to keep the
level of violence relatively low and
that's a good thing for Israelis
final question what is Victory going to
look like here I mean if there are still
Hamas terrorists alive at the end of
this is that Victory or do they simply
buy their time regroup and come back at
Israel even stronger because so many
people will have been killed by then in
Gaza so when Victory is the destruction
of hamas's military machine and the end
of their political control over the Gaza
trip a bit like victory over Isis in
Iraq and Syria you didn't have to kill
every last Isis gunman but you destroyed
their territorial Independence you
destroyed their ability to to control an
enclave because that gives them power we
can't destroy the Hamas idea just as you
can't destroy the Isis idea but you can
remove from them the capability to
inflict pain on others and and we
believe that once we have destroyed
hamas's Terror regime in Gaza there'll
be room to build something better for
the Palestinians they can build it
themselves we'll support them uh but
let's speak be clear here when this is
over hamas's path of extremism of
radicalism of violence of Terror will be
discredited not because it hurt us but
because it hurt the people of Gaza I
mean the people of Gaza are not stupid
they can see who started this war who
brought all this destruction upon them
who even ended the ceasefire by refusing
to to release more hostages the people
of Gaza know this they can't speak their
minds today because they live in a
terrible dictatorial State Hamas does
not allow people to criticize them and
and not face consequences violent
consequences but when this is over and
the people of Gaza can speak they will
say that Hamas brought this tragedy upon
them and there'll be room I think to
work with Palestinian moderates to build
a better future for Gaza it's good for
Israel it's good for gazans Mr thank you
very much one question for you uh I
would love to interview prime minister
Netanyahu I interviewed him back in
March when he was in London I've put in
a number of requests he's not spoken yet
to any European media entity only
American once could we have an interview
with prime minister
Netanyahu so so I'll I'll check that out
with the Prime Minister I know he's
interviewed in the past and he's enjoyed
that and he could well do it again I
just can't commit for him at the moment
uh he has been focused on American Media
I think we've done I think 95% of our
interviews have been directed to the US
market because the US market the
Americans are our most important Ally as
you well understand well Britain has
proven to be a pretty good Ally too so
that's why I'm asking the question I
think it might be you 100% correct
Britain Britain has been a good Ally in
this in this conflict so has Germany and
we know to appreciate our friends well
it would be good it would be good to be
interiew the Prime Minister if he could
spare us the time if you could pass that
message to him I will speak to him about
it the next time I see him thank you
very much appreciate it Mr Reger thank
you on set next the un's women's rights
body finally condemns herass for its
appalling sexual violence almost two
months after the attack my next guest
says it's feminist to support Palestine
and demand a ceasefire well that's a
debate coming
up
[Music]
we're here thanks for joining us you
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about talk today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tories love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police appr Pro Palestine
that is just not right you swear an off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a f or a tragedy
there needs to be one human per machine
to come and rectify beats and the clanks
and when it goes R unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our biased news going to come
from at Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden deci this is important
after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV welcome back there's a shocking and
growing body of evidence that Hamas used
extreme sexual violence against women
throughout us attacks on October the 7th
un women has been strongly criticized
for taking 57 days to condemn those
atrocities why did it take them so long
to say something why have we so many in
the feminist movement uh why they sided
with Palestine a culture where Women's
Rights barely exist well these are
important questions J know as Chief
foreign correspondent Sunday Times
Christina L the hosted to Tommy Len his
steers an out kick Tommy Len and author
and journalist Julius line well thank
you all of you Chris let me start with
you you wrote this gut-wrenching piece
of Journalism uh on Sunday it really
moved me almost to tears actually
reading the detail of what you'd
Unearthed about the barbaric rapes and
sexual attacks on women on October the
7th just summarize really your findings
yeah I mean we should warn a few it's um
horrific but basically I talked to a lot
of people but in particular I talked to
survivors of the Supernova Music
Festival which was one of the places
that was attacked by Hamas on October
the 7th and some of those people told me
about witnessing girls being raped gang
raped and one man in particular
who um hid under the body of a woman
that was shot and then was for hours
trying to get out of there he saw a
number of girls being raped but he told
me in particular about one who was raped
by about 10 Hamas Fighters um and she
was just begging them to kill her
actually because she was just it was
just so horrific what they were doing
and he said that she had the face of an
Angel and that he wakes every night now
to see that face and they did in the end
kill her I think in that case did they
shot her it was incredibly disturbing as
has been some of the reaction to all
these Revelations you know normally you
would see the feminist movement around
the world rallying as one to speak out
about this and yet we're seeing a lot of
Silence we're seeing a lot of female
congresswoman in America going out of
their way not to condemn what happened
to try and deflect it's been a very
bizarre reaction what do you make of
that no absolutely I think this has all
got mixed up in the politics of it and
you know whatever you think I mean I
personally think you can completely it's
completely compatble to be horrified by
what Israel is doing in Gaza in terms of
the number of civilians are being killed
and be horrified at what happened on
October the 7th and it was very strange
that feminist groups un others around
the world did not speak about it because
you know there was really right from the
beginning on the actual day hamus was
live streaming videos which made clear
they were doing it in plain sight and
boasting gleefully about what they were
doing but un women I mean if they if
they can't speak out sooner than 57 days
on the systematic rape and abuse and
murder of women what what's their
purpose I mean the one thing I would say
having covered this a lot and in
different conflicts it does often take a
long time to come out and that's because
you know this is such a difficult thing
for people to come out and speak about
as we all know rape is the one crime
where the victim is often made to feel
that they did something wrong so it's
hard for people to talk about it they're
horrific things that have happened and
in this case people will say well where
are the victims right we know victims
have actually come forward and spoken
yes now that may be because they were
all killed or taken hostage or it may be
that there are the state department in
America was saying today they believe a
lot of the female hostages who've not
been released are being sexually
assaulted you know I I'm sad to say I
think that that is happening I spoke to
the mother of a 23y old who was taken
hostage at that festival and she's you
know absolutely tearing herself apart
thinking I mean she has says I have to
not think about that it's horrific
horrific let me bring in uh Tommy and
Judith here so Tommy what is going on
here what why are so many female
so-called progressives simply finding it
impossible to come out and scream from
the rooftops about the systematic rape
and sexual abuse of women by
Hamas well Piers it's because the
modernday feminist movement is a farce
and it's a joke they don't stand up for
women Israeli women who are brutally
raped and tortured they don't stand up
for women's sports the Integrity of our
Sports and our spaces they don't stand
up for anything beyond unfettered
abortions the modern day feminist
movement is not the feminist movement
that was created to empower women to
protect women to guide women now it's
about abortion and that's about it and I
wish that weren't the case the UN is
also worthless why we in the United
States continue to fund that body is
beyond me but it's also quite disgusting
to watch American politicians play the
mental gymnastics around what happened
on October 7th and try to then
repeatedly turn it back on Israel as if
Israeli soldiers are indiscriminately
raping those in Palestine and in Gaza
which we know is not the case so what
this is is evil it's blatant
anti-Semitism and it needs to be called
out forcefully and at every turn
feminism is a joke the is a joke and
unfortunately a lot of our American
politicians also a joke Piers okay
Judith your response to
that uh well as a Jewish American
feminist I would uh argue with the idea
that American feminists are not uh
deploring the or Jews or even people as
Christina said uh who are deploring what
Israel is doing in Palestine also uh
speak about the at roties that Hamas has
committed against uh Jewish people in in
Israel and and elsewhere and against
their own people as well so uh it is
completely consistent to look at both of
these things happening and also to say
that um as many um activists and people
with long experience on both sides of
the walls have said that uh neither the
Palestinians nor the Jews in Israel or
anybody else in Israel will have
security unless there is peace uh and as
unless there is Justice uh in Palestine
these are PE the Jews are not going
anywhere the Palestinians are not going
anywhere only some kind of political
solution is possible and uh I would
remind Tommy that feminists are really
the people who speak about rape we're
the only people really who speak speak
constantly about rape uh what happened I
I think probably what happened as
Christina said in the UN is that
everything moves really slowly at the un
uh the UN gathers information then they
have to have some sort of consensus on
what they put out and so I don't know
that there was some sort of you know
conspiracy against Jews in not
publishing uh what happened um and also
those particular horrific acts came out
out later yeah I think we all knew
though from from day one a lot of rape
had occurred because it was being
boasted about by the people doing the
raping and that's the key difference I
also think with the UN women had you
know had Hamas used the wrong personal
pronouns that day they'd have been
straight on it on Twitter because that's
the uh that's unfortunately what they
seem to be seeing as one of their
priorities and I find that ridiculous um
but anyway uh thank you to my panel
greatly appreciate Christina what an
amazing piece of Journalism at the
weekend honestly one of the most
powerful things I've read in a long long
time do incredible work even though it
was it was incredibly distressing it's
so important so thank you thank you very
much un sensor next Riz is Ox
University's word of a year but what is
Riz am I rizz do I want to be Riz pack
will tell me
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online onun your smart speak we as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well Tred most dog owners will tell you
a dog can turn do you know what I love
about sport today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tor love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the a pro Palestine that is just not
right you swear an off in the police to
act without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for AIT if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about 3 years hundreds and hundreds
of mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man McAn he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cru
Phil sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do I'm going
you're going to Res yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group
have a rational I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
welcome back to on Jo my pack talk TV
contributor Esther KRA by theal
journalist a Santina who I last saw on
the morning show this morning so a big
stint for you today on talk TV
congratulations get enough uh exactly
exactly um let's talk immigration Esther
big new fivepoint roll out by the new
Home Secretary James cleverly designed
to Target and bring down our legal
migration numbers what do you make of it
well this cabinet is clearly obsessed
with five points I don't know why um but
I do think that it it's addressing some
hard truths at the end of the day you
know the government has to realize that
this kind of uh immigration is
unsustainable they've raised the minimum
um threshold to get a work visa to um
salary threshold to 38,700 which is like
over £10,000 above the minimum now and
excludes the NHS and Care exactly but
you cannot offer a 20% work um sort of
discount for workers in in areas that
have uh shortages which totally makes
sense at the end of the day Britain has
to make a choice we can be drunk on on
foreign labor and be obsessed with mass
migration or we can choose to make these
businesses make hard choices to train up
and our own population right and the
problem it seem to me a with the whole
thing is when you look you crunch the
numbers take the ones who come in for
our Health and Care Service right there
were like a 100 or thousand that come in
but there were 120,000 dependents who
came with them and of those only 25%
were getting work so 75% were basically
living off the state that seems to me to
be part of the the execution of a
previous plan was flawed so you're going
to invite people to come over here and
work in our NHS and serve us serve us
you know serve the country and then tell
them they can't bring can't bring their
spouse but you know you you talked about
hard truth a minute ago let's talk about
actual hard truth okay so the
conservatives right now haven't built
any housing they haven't built you know
they haven't brought in any more GPS
we've got a failing NHS why is that it's
because of the government it's nothing
to do with immigration it's actually a
lot to do with immigration IM all the
points you've made with all the points
you made you worsen it by having
uncontrolled Mass migration because if
we're not building enough houses it
doesn't have 750,000 people doesn't
exist if you hang on we just had record
750,000 net migration last year that is
uncontrolled mtion and we've got an
aging population that is dependent on
the state pension so we need to have
have we do have in my estimation one of
the biggest problems we have a lazy
entitled population with 5 million
people are now off work because they're
all sick right million you sound like
that that book that quy quing
and and by the way I've working in this
country but now we're conflating two
different issues here because let's
actually look at migration let's look at
that you know the numbers or the amount
of money that immigration brings in they
are they net 3% positive that's how much
they bring to our
Eon clear you would carry on allowing
three4 of a million people a year net to
come into this country yes yes I would
so over the next 10 years you'd have
nearly 8 million people come in I would
argue legally well you would the
population will increase by that you
can't both go to me let me actually
answer we argued for this during brexit
you wanted Global Britain we wanted you
know and you wanted no you wanted people
to contribute to the economy and people
are coming in here cont half of those
people are not doing that because they
all
dependent mtion fine we've got your
position and there's going to be 100
million people here and no one will have
a job no one can go to nothing the AA
Santina positive very quickly let's talk
about Riz are you Riz am I Riz you I
hate that word um the Oxford at
University press says it's the word of
the Year internet slang apparently for
romantic appeal or Charm it means to
chat up if you have if you had good chat
do I have or not well I've seen your
wife you obviously have good chat you
obviously have RZ does it work on you uh
yes it actually does I require R am I am
I it's not just in dating you know it's
like you know so when you're
interviewing someone you've got to bit
of RZ you know you have people in here
who you've never met before you can get
good stuff out of them that's a bit of
RZ I think you and do women have Riz too
um depends on the know I depend I I
don't really have RZ I don't need RZ I
don't like to give a lot of RZ yeah I I
don't need it you know what I'll take we
take RZ I'll take a should we all agree
we've all got a little bit of Riz a
little bit it's a Sprinkle good to see
you pack that's it from me whatever
you're up to keep it un centered and
keep a bit of Riz in your life good
[Music]
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
to today we do it all soon Act sella
gun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this Hammer
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
on to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tores love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with soel braan she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
has booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomime there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for Sadi Khan we're not stopping until
you stop
the amount of time it's taken the number
of illegal migrants currently sent by us
to Rwanda zil the amount of money it's
cost we're saying what are we saying
it's cost about 140 million £140 million
so far so40 million so far result nil
absolutely nil are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man MC Mouse man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit president
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film